the out of Crisis comes understanding
and uh
a certain kind of
what a piece
with whatever it was that happened that
was the Catalyst for the crisis you know
and if you haven't been through it then
if you haven't been through any crises
in your life first of all I don't know
anybody who hasn't yeah I don't know
anyone yeah so so we're all
kind of brothers and sisters in that
regard that we all have that in common
and Humanity does right some of us
recognize that some of us don't but I I
think one of the things about
being an actor is that it
it says to people look
this is do you see something of yourself
in this situation or in this character
uh and that's the great gift that we're
able to to share with people
yeah I feel like a lot of my things the
things that came out were ego a lot of
ego things I was upset by things because
maybe they didn't go my way or I wasn't
in control
um yeah you talked about your first
marriage was that something that wasn't
your choice that you didn't want to
divorce uh at the time no but but in
retrospect it was the best thing that
could have happened for me at that time
uh because it made me
look at some things that I'd never
looked at before that I'd taken for
granted right you know ways that I uh
dealt with other people with women uh in
particular which kind of mirrored my
relationship with my mom if you get into
the kind of the therapeutic part of it
right
um so uh it was revelatory I didn't
necessarily completely learn my lesson
the first time
yeah I had to get married again right
and uh and and ended up
happily for a time and also having
children which was really important to
me and I have three kids now and I have
nine grandchildren wow uh my children
are grown up and I have you know this
hassle of grandchildren that are just
the Delight of my life uh and then that
marriage ended in a kind of a crisis
situation that was actually the Catalyst
was financial trouble ah that on that
tongue and uh and now I'm married for uh
well married for more than 25 years but
together with Mike my wife Joanna for
over 30 years we've got the 30 years
that's amazing and we live we have a
wonderful life we have these
grandchildren so it all of that if if it
had my first marriage hadn't ended
this this life that I'm living now
wouldn't have existed isn't that
something so when something bad happens
you have to know that you're going to
learn from it and hopefully something
good from it that's meant to be if you
believe that is going to happen yeah and
then your first wife was Susan Sarandon
obviously correct and I didn't know that
until I read about it yeah I mean and
she took your name right
she did yeah and she still she still
owes me do you guys even talk or was it
was it we haven't we haven't talked in a
long time uh although we do stay in
touch uh uh occasionally because I've
had a very strong relationship she's one
of a number of children she's the oldest
of eight or nine I can't remember now
how many but I I had a relationship with
all of her siblings when I was she and I
were married and so uh I and her parents
whom I knew well uh and actually her mom
ended up being a friend of my mom's post
this is like you know maybe 15 years ago
um because they lived in the same town
and they ended up connecting but um uh
no we we don't we're not in sort of
constant touch I think one of the
reasons probably is we didn't have
children together right whereas whereas
my uh ex Lisa and I have three kids
together and we're still you know they
we have Thanksgiving together she and
her husband come down with their kids
because they've had a couple of kids
since uh Lisa and I divorced and we all
got together and we hang out and she and
my Joanna are good friends that's that
is you don't hear that very often